what you inherit from your parents
biologically impacts your outcomes in
life anxiety alcoholism depression
happiness set point IQ shoe size
everything at least 50 of pretty much
everything that you are isn't determined
by your environment there's all manner
of weird versions of you sitting inside
of sperm and eggs and it can come
together and it can be oh it's not you
it's actually your great great grandpa
who happened to have this weird Quirk
you could have some creative grandfather
who was an artist or a musician you have
a friend Dr Stu McGill he's the number
one back pain specialist on the planet
who has spent his entire life doing
science and hard things built his own
house one daughter became a ship captain
other son became something to do with
architecture I think I can see the line
the third son went to theater school
he's a Savage but it's very different
and I don't know where the did that come
from